i think it's time to finally talk about
losing weight
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by builtbar
and we will be finally touching on a
topic that you ask me
a lot and that is sustainable weight
loss
now i'm gonna be looking at some of your
favorite weight loss
youtubers and sharing some of the
recommendations that i
actually can support but before i get
into it i want to chat about my sponsor
buildbar
now i have to be totally honest i
usually
really don't like protein bars not
because i think that there's anything
inherently wrong with them
nutritionally i actually think that
they're a really good option for kind of
like sneaking in protein on those really
crazy busy days
but i usually think they kind of taste
like chalk
and honestly i would way rather eat
a bowl of plain egg whites or chicken
breasts
for protein rather than flavored chalk
so when they sent me these bars i
totally told my agent that i fully
expected to hate them and then i tried
one
and then i tried another one and another
one
and let me just tell you they were
pretty good
so today's flavor for my snacking
enjoyment is their
white chocolate cookies and cream let's
take a little
taste shall we so
yummy i wouldn't care if these were like
straight-up chocolate bars i would
still be here talking about them because
they taste like the love child between
a marshmallow and a nougat bar also i
have to laugh
at the zero guilt label on the package
unless you stole it
all food is zero guilt in my opinion
nutrition wise
each bar has 17 grams of protein so they
are ideal if you want to add it to
a snack or to a meal to like bump up the
satiety factor
and since they are lower in sugar if i
were to have this as like a post-workout
snack
i would always pair it with some fruit
or like a piece of toast
to balance the protein with carbs and
the natural sugars
i also should flag that they are
sweetened with erythritol
and i know that some people are
sensitive to fodmaps like sugar alcohols
but it's actually one of the best
tolerated sugar alcohols because it's
largely resistant to bacterial
fermentation but i'm also not one to
limit actual sugar either so
i'm easy on that front in general but i
know that everyone has their own goals
and preferences
and to me honestly the most impressive
part about this was just that it tasted
super delicious and good so if you want
to try it you can
check out my link below in the
description for 20 off your order
all right let's talk weight loss now
while you know that this is
not a weight loss channel and will
continue to not be
a weight loss channel over the past year
or so
my professional position has really
changed
and i've come to appreciate the
importance of meeting people where they
are
and to me that means honoring all health
and aesthetic goals
including those that include weight loss
it's really not up to me to decide
whether or not that is a good or bad
goal
or whether you will succeed or fail so
i want to clarify that i am not haze
and i'm also not strict pro weight loss
i'm all about living in the gray
and i'm willing to help people meet
their goals the healthiest most
sustainable
way possible now as you have seen on my
channel
i am a big proponent of intuitive eating
and intuitive eating as it was
originally conceptualized by its authors
in its entirety with the 10 guiding
principles that we talk about
is an amazing freeing place to get to
but i don't think that it's realistic
for everyone to achieve complete
food freedom and i also that we can gain
a lot from even incorporating
one or two or more of the principles
into our lives
having said that while intuitive eating
is not a diet
and does not explicitly prescribe weight
loss advice
i also don't think that there's anything
wrong with the desire to lose weight
in fact diet culture is so pervasive in
our aesthetic driven
instagramable world that i think it's
really hard
not to have those desires obviously in
an ideal world
those with weight loss goals should be
working with a registered dietitian to
find
a sustainable and healthy diet pattern
that works for them
but i get that accessing that support
isn't always so easy
hence the popularity of weight loss
youtubers and
influencers but if you've watched any of
my review videos
you know that there is a ton of
misinformation out there
a lot of which can be really dangerous
in the wrong hands
now i also want to preface this by
saying that if you're trying to lose
weight following
any of the advice you find online and
it's not
working you are not broken you are not
doing it wrong nothing about weight loss
is simple or straightforward
because our bodies are actually designed
to fight it
and will do so to variable degrees
between people
or at different stages in your life so
it worked in your 20s
probably won't work so well in your 40s
but that doesn't mean that long-term
weight loss is impossible the key to me
is that it must be a way of living that
you can sustain
and ultimately enjoy for life not a
cleanse
not a detox not an over-the-top
restrictive set of rules
we have got to bring it back to basics
as
unsexy as that is also before we start
check out the disclaimers on the screen
including
an obvious huge trigger warning this
is not and i repeat not
a video for those struggling with
disordered eating remember we cannot
directly control
how our body loses weight we can only
control
our behaviors now i also want to add
that i don't necessarily agree with
everything that these influencers
suggest on their entire channel
when it comes to weight loss or health
advice and i also
don't always agree with their delivery
or tone or communication style
finally don't forget to subscribe to
this channel and ring that little bell
so that you never miss out on a future
video
all right folks let's kick this video
off with a familiar face here on abby's
kitchen
john from obese to beast so john's
message
is largely rooted in moderation as
opposed to complete
deprivation with an emphasis put on
improving health
so let's take a look at one of his
suggestions first tip i actually have
is to eat more calories and i know that
might sound like well
i'm trying to lose weight while i eat
more calories something i notice is that
a lot of people
they are cutting their calories way too
drastically
if you're a 300 pound person and you're
eating a thousand calories
yes you are going to be losing weight
but obviously you're going to be
very hungry because you can be eating a
lot more calories
i 100 agree not only are major caloric
deficits
subject to cause metabolic adaptation
which i discuss in my video
right here but also risks you following
into an
overeating episode or an actual binge
it's actually really easy to undo a
caloric deficit from
one epic cheat meal a week so that's
something to keep in mind if you keep
finding yourself
restricting so aggressively that you
can't help
but overeat now john also talks about
eating enough fat protein and fiber
every meal
which frequent viewers of my channel may
recognize as the hunger crushing
combination
so i appreciate this advice not only
because each of these compounds help to
increase the satiety factor of food
but also because john is focusing on
what we can
add to our diet rather than always
thinking about what we need to just take
away
and i find that this little shift in
mentality can really help keep us out of
that scarcity mentality
which is a really typical predictor of a
binge
now while i typically don't agree with
complete avoidance of any kind of food
i do think that there is some merit to
john's
next piece of advice around drinking
your calories
let's take a look is to stop drinking
your calories now this goes obviously
for sodas and sugary juices and
smoothies
all of that stuff is adding calories
that are not going to make you feel full
okay so i don't think that we need to
never
have a drink with calories if you enjoy
a glass of wine or smoothie or fresh
juice
but there definitely is some value from
an evidence-based
gentle nutrition standpoint to his
suggestions
obviously we know that soda pop isn't a
nutrient-dense choice
but even when we think about something
like fruit juice which
does contain a lot of micronutrients it
would be
a lot more satiating and probably
also more emotionally satisfying to eat
like
four whole oranges rather than drink a
glass of oj
same with a smoothie which while more
satiating than juice because you're
getting more fiber intact
may not be the equivalent experience of
eating
a banana and peanut butter and yogurt
and milk and spinach
in a bowl in fact one study comparing
the satiety effects
of consuming fruit smoothies versus
their fresh
fruit equivalents found that a fruit
salad
was substantially more filling than its
equivalent
drink so if you're trying to focus on
the satiety factor of the foods that you
choose
go for foods that you chew
now finally another one of my favorite
pieces of advice from john
is to slow down your eating pace
let's take a look but make sure that you
are not completely wolfing your food
down in about 30 seconds
try and make sure that you're chewing
every single bite and enjoying the food
that you're having because if you're
eating it in 10 seconds
you're like i'm still hungry and then
you can continue eating so
this is great advice for everyone not
just for those looking to
lose weight since it also helps with
aiding in digestion
and as a busy mama i myself really
need to take note but we do know that it
takes about 20 minutes for our stomach
to communicate satiety to our brain
and most of us today eat so fast
that we never really acknowledge those
cues until it's too late
so slowing down is a great way to
encourage ourselves to check in
regularly
before we find ourselves overeating now
i also can say that i really appreciate
jon's personal
laid-back approach to food we often see
him eating
typically demonized foods like white
bread
but he also doesn't cut out full food
groups and he eats the foods that he
enjoys
that fit generally within what he has
already established
as his caloric and macro needs and while
he's mindful of his caloric intake
he has also said often that he will eat
more on days if he does feel hungry
so all of these level-headed tactics to
maintain his significant weight loss
get a big yes from me okay so
moving on let's talk about some
suggestions from weight loss youtuber
jordan shrinks now in her video top 5
best foods for weight loss and healthy
food swaps
jordan talks about a variety of her
favorite
high volume nutrient dense foods like
fruits
veggies popcorn potatoes and oatmeal
all of which help provide satiety for
fewer calories
now while i think this volume eating
advice can be taken
to an extreme and become super
problematic
as we have seen in some of my reviews
like dr dre for example
when i look at jordan's what eight in a
days it suggests that she's eating
normal portions of these high volume
foods
and then balancing them with lots of
healthy fats
and protein i also see that jordan
incorporates a lot of
non-local foods like peanut butter toast
chickpea pasta
chicken skewers and protein bars
suggesting that you still need calories
and substance in your diet to complement
some of those
higher volume lower calorie fruits and
veg
i mean one just cannot subsist on
lettuce alone
so i think it can be triggering for some
people to be told hey
fill your belly with all these low
calorie foods at its core
we're really just talking about eating
more fiber-rich
water-rich foods and generally that
means
fruits and veggies that is kind of as
nutrition 101
as it gets so i do agree with that while
research in the area of
volumetrics is somewhat consistent
most of the data to date has found that
when calories are equal
people report greater satiety following
a more
volumous meal or snack so for example
comparing 100 calories worth of
strawberries
to 100 calories worth of chocolate chips
the strawberries are probably going to
be
more satiating jordan also talks about
finding ways to make the foods you love
but in more nutritious ways so let's
take a look
it's so much better when you're losing
weight to learn how to make the foods
you love in a healthier way
like you're just going to do yourself
such a service if you take the time
to figure out how to make things you
love in a healthier way because that
means you don't have to give up the
things you like
that means you're not going to feel
deprived but you're still going to be
reaching your health goals so
i agree i mean i think that food skills
are highly
underrated in our society but research
does suggest
that weight loss intervention programs
that include home cooking
do improve weight loss outcomes as well
as overall diet quality
now i also checked out her video on the
five common weight loss myths
and we see a few of the same themes that
we already discussed with john
so you know she talks about making sure
that you're eating enough
avoiding things like crash diets and not
taking exercise to an extreme
and then she also busts some common
myths that i
often discuss on my channel here so
let's take a look
and that is that carbs make you gain
weight so one of the main reasons why
people assume or think that carbs make
you gain weight
is one they've been told that by the
diet industry so i don't blame anyone
but two is after consuming carbs you are
likely to see an increase on the scale
what's important to remember about this
is that that increase on the scale is
not an increase in fat it's an increase
of water
yes to diet culture and yes to water
weight
carbs should not be feared
also this one you do not have to drink
juice for a week before you can start
losing weight
yup if you are an avid watcher of abby's
kitchen
you've heard that one a lot so it is
nice to feel echoed by another youtuber
in this space your body is a
natural cleansing machine
yeah you might lose some weight on a
three-day juice fast
but that's going to be all water weight
and potentially muscle if it goes on
long enough
so you're going to gain all that back
when you start to actually
eat again so in conclusion while not a
professional
jordan's moderate simplistic and
realistic approach to weight loss is
something to be
admired in this insane youtube space
and her own significant weight loss
success is a testament to that
all right moving on to another common
request
i want to chat about lena from frumpyfit
so in her video should you avoid certain
foods to lose weight
she talks about her all foods fit
philosophy to dieting
where no specific foods are off limits
because to her
nutrition should be all about moderation
not restriction
yes girl lena
music to my ear she also talks about how
completely eliminating certain
bad foods you love often backfires
and can just cause you to overeat
yep she's definitely right about that
you know i will say it all the time but
absolute restriction
is generally a pretty good setup for a
binge
now elena's approach to weight loss is
based on mindfulness strategies and
activities
to help release foods from what she
calls our food biases
let's take a look re-evaluate your food
biases
a huge reason that people tend to
overeat certain foods
is that it's a result of restriction and
the reason we restrict
certain foods is because we label them
as bad like we're not supposed to be
eating them
they're forbidden and then by making
them off limits it makes us want them
more
and then we end up binging you've
probably experienced it in your own life
and your own diet and as a fitness
professional i see this happen
all the time massive restriction leads
to binging
almost always yep
you know i always talk about how
dichotomizing food is good or bad or
painting foods with a moral lens
often sets us up to obsess and overeat
the alleged
junk i mean i know that all foods are
obviously not nutritionally equal
but if we make them morally equal we're
much more likely to be able to eat in
response to
physical rather than just our emotional
needs
now in her video the best diet for
weight loss in 2020
she explains the concept of flexible
dieting
so basically this is the idea that you
can calculate your caloric needs
and eat within those guidelines now i
want to flag that
i'm not a fan of strict calorie counting
for
everyone partially because i think it's
a flawed science where
one online calculators really can't do
your unique metabolic needs justice
and two food manufacturers can also be
legally
off by 20 percent on their calorie
counts
what i do like about this idea of
flexible dieting
is that it discourages cutting out whole
foods
or food groups and it doesn't encourage
any other bogus non-evidence-based rules
and restrictions so for example here's
what lena suggests
are her guidelines for flexible dieting
that i can
definitely get behind what i tell my
clients is to eat a minimum
of three to four servings of veggies per
day two to three servings of fruit per
day
and also to make sure that they're
drinking enough water and they're eating
enough
fiber yes weight loss or not
all of these suggestions are great
evidence-based gentle nutrition
recommendations
and do not seem punishing at all so even
if you don't want to track calories
and just want to focus on some of these
strategies right here
you will absolutely see benefits to your
health
and as for weight loss obviously if you
decide to add
three servings of fruit or veg to your
diet and change nothing else
it's not going to help you lose weight
but this is where that intuition piece
comes in
if you are adding three servings of
fruits and veggies
you'll likely feel more satiated due to
their high
fiber content which will likely result
in edging out some of those
higher calorie highly processed foods
and i think yes
weight loss does come down to calories
even
if counting calories or manipulating
them is as i've said a bit of a flawed
science
and if you want to better understand the
nuances of calories
and why it's not quite as simple as just
eat less
you can watch my video on metabolic
damage here but i like that her unique
approach to flexible dieting
is also grounded in some of the
principles of
intuitive eating let's take a look one
of the huge reasons why i think flexible
dieting
is the best diet for weight loss is
because
there's an end in my opinion there's an
end goal
one of the main reasons that i think
flexible dieting is so great
is that it teaches you so much about
food when you do flexible dieting for an
extended period of time
you gain this really deep understanding
of how
food plays a role in your life you learn
about
how certain foods make you feel you
learn about how
much of a certain food you really need
to eat to feel
satisfied or to get the fuel in that you
need for that day or your workout or
whatever it is
because when you're tracking your food
you're paying attention to it
and the appeal with a lot of other diets
is that you don't really have to pay
attention to that stuff
you just know what you can and can't eat
and you go for it
but i think you're doing yourself a
disservice by not
learning about the food that you're
eating i don't disagree
i mean one of my professional criticisms
of flexible dieting
is that people sometimes use it to
justify eating a lot of kind of low
nutrition foods
with the argument that it's okay because
it fits their macros
that's not untrue from an energy balance
standpoint
but as lena often points out doing this
won't actually make you feel very good
and the goal of healthful eating should
be to
feel healthy and satisfied and sustain
these behaviors long
term again i don't think everyone
needs to count calories to get to this
place of understanding how
foods make you feel but if having that
data
is helpful for you in this process and
not triggering great i mean you do you
use that tool all right moving on to
another
jordan let's talk about fitness creator
jordan
syat now in his video how to lose weight
without counting calories
he talks about the typical cycle of
restrictive dieting
getting initial results hitting a
plateau
and then quitting his advice is that
successful programs
need to be sustained for at least six
months to a year
before we see long-term meaningful
habits emerge
i also love that he points out how any
diet can result in weight loss
whether that's low carb or high carb
keto atkins paleo etc
so let's take a look what can you do
not for a week not for 14 days not for
21 days not 30 days
what can you do for a year two years
five years your whole life
that is the defining factor i 100
percent
agree i always say that the healthiest
diet
is the one that you can actually sustain
for life
everything else is just a miserable and
futile exercise
and quite frankly a waste of precious
time
he also talks about the ultimate goal in
making these behaviors
part of your life so let's take a look
and the ultimate level
of advanced dieting advanced nutrition
advanced fitness the ultimate highest
level
is where you don't have to think about
it
so i know that that can sound completely
unattainable for a lot of people
watching right now and it may be
depending on what kind of
weight you're trying to hold yourself to
or whether or not that is
kind of a healthy happy weight for you
but ultimately yes the goal should be
to live your life without constant
intrusive thoughts about your weight
and food i've said it many times
having an overwhelming desire to lose
weight is 100 percent
valid and normal but it's a long game
to health and happiness and also it's a
bit of a balance
if we go at this too hard too fast we
set ourselves
up for a binge or burnout and that
typically results in
weight regain or even a weight that is
greater than where you start it
i also find that his approach to doing a
mini cut for fallos which is generally a
pretty aggressive protocol
is a lot more moderate than the norm so
let's take a look a lot of people say
because it's a very brief period of time
it allows you to be more strict and
that's not wrong
that is one way to structure a mini cut
and it can work very well depending on
your goals
for me personally based on the content
that i put out based on the type of
health and lifestyle i want people to
live i'm usually not trying to put out
content that is
outrageously strict and rigid because
that doesn't doesn't really jive with my
way of approaching life and fitness
overall
i have to say um that while if for
whatever reason
fat loss was my goal and it's not
this would totally be my approach too
so for jordan his mini cut meant trying
to lose around 10 pounds
over the course of 10 weeks that is a
surprisingly
reasonable time frame for those kinds of
results
as for jordan's method he brings it back
to basics for people who
don't want to count calories and focuses
instead
on a more approachable and simplified
plate method
so let's take a look replates two snacks
method of fat loss this is my go-to
method of fat loss
that i use if someone does not want to
count their calories
because it's a very simple way of
moderating your overall portion control
okay so this is not unlike the gentle
nutrition tips that i give in
all of my videos that you see me review
where i'm talking about building
generally balanced plates jordan's
recommending that each plate contain
some satiating protein and high fiber
veg
and to build snacks about the size of
your palm so for example
an apple or a cup of greek yogurt he
also leaves room for fun foods that he
loves like peanut m
ms but again he's sticking to his
general rule of thumb
of snacks being the size of his palm i
think that this is a totally reasonable
approach to eating
that allows space for your favorite
foods while not letting them
edge out more nutrient-dense snacks and
meals
a handful of m ms in the context of a
diet with lots of fruits and veg
is really not a big deal especially if
it helps you
enjoy your life and maintain your health
promoting routine
in the long term now in terms of
training jordan is
not about just burning as many calories
as possible he is all about building
metabolic health
through resistance training and the
evidence suggests that this
actually is a really smart approach to
take for long-term
body composition and weight loss while
cardio may burn more calories in the
moment
resistance training boosts resting
metabolic rate for
hours after a training session and it
increases metabolism
in the long run i also appreciate that
he approaches
exercise in a sustainable approachable
way
let's take a look but if you want to
make this not just for fat loss but for
overall health if you want to improve
your health and your lifestyle improve
your mobility
improve your endurance improve your
cardio improve your health getting in
daily steps is super important it's just
something i think everyone should have
in their routine every single day so i
think that this is really great
accessible advice walking or even just
incorporating more movement into your
day
makes fitting in activity more realistic
it doesn't need to be a hardcore six day
a week crossfit regime
to be beneficial so in general i think
that it's really refreshing to hear from
a successful fitness competitor and
coach
that strategies to work towards weight
loss and fat loss
can be flexible and can fit into your
existing life
finally the last creator i'm pulling
advice from today is probably going to
turn some heads
mainly because my critique of his videos
maybe was not
super flattering however as i mentioned
in that video
i do think that greg ducette knows his
stuff
in his video do these every day to help
lose weight and keep it off permanently
he prefaces his list by suggesting that
success is not dependent on you doing
all the things but even just
incorporating a few can play a role in
meeting your goals
yes yes yes to not taking on
too much too fast that is in my
experience
the fastest most reliable road to
throwing in the towel
and see-sawing all the way back to
unhealthy
behaviors an all-or-nothing approach is
in my opinion
just not compatible with long-term
success
so he suggests things like eating more
fruits and veggies lifting weights to
build metabolically active muscle mass
drinking more water eating regular meals
and snacks
getting in satiating protein and
avoiding over
training all of these are in my
professional opinion
solid evidence-based examples of gentle
nutrition
in another video called top 10 things to
avoid when trying to lose weight
greg goes on a rant about why you should
not
skip meals and i gotta say i
am so here for it let's take a look
fasting and skipping meals
don't be like oh i have to lose weight
so i know what i'll do i'll skip
breakfast and lunch and i'll only eat at
supper time i'm only gonna eat before
bed i only eat in the morning and at
night
or i'll just skip this meal because then
i can eat more calories later
no it doesn't work like that if you skip
meals your body goes into like
starvation mode and it sends signals
you're extra hungry and then you end up
binging and cheating and then you over
consume
food at night you eventually cave crack
down
and over consume more calories than if
you actually stuck to the plan
yep that again is why i always say
one of the best predictors of a binge is
restriction
let's see what else he has to say big
one huge one
do not lose weight too fast so many
people
they'll start a diet and lose like 25
pounds the first month
yeah it's motivating because you see the
scale weight dropping so quick and you
think you're doing amazing
you're losing muscle muscle burns
calories muscle makes your metabolism
higher yep pretty much
and this my friends is why i say
crash diets do not work
let's see what else eating too strict
cutting out food groups and stuff going
keto
saying oh i can only eat chicken rice
and broccoli
chicken tilapia and some fish and
cutting out all sweets
all junk all yummy delicious foods in
your whole life
that doesn't work long term it might
work short term
if you have extreme discipline you might
be able to follow that diet for a little
while
i could probably do it but i'm very very
uh
motivated to reach my goals but even i
wouldn't want to do it long term
why do that when you can have balance
balance is not all
or nothing balance is eating healthy but
still having some foods you like
okay so i want to preface this by saying
greg and i
may have different ideas about what
constitutes fun foods and balance
so while egg white french toast and
anabolic ice cream and popcorn
may be fun for greg for others they may
just be kind of like healthified
versions of
junk food still tasty and fun but
potentially not a full replacement for
moderate portions
of the real deal what i do 100 agree
with is the sentiment that if you are
bored as [ __ ]
eating the same bland chicken and sweet
potato meal prep dinner
you are not going to keep it up
again greg obviously loves popcorn and
his anabolic ice cream and things like
that
so if having these foods in his diet
every day
makes it sustainable and enjoyable for
him to still
meet his nutritional goals amazing
but i also want to clarify that getting
out of that all or nothing mentality
can also take the form of the flexible
and varied approach
that other youtubers were suggesting you
know different people will respond to
different levels of flexibility
and routine that is totally a personal
thing i think the take-home message here
is that
you don't have to take on a punishing
regime
that has you avoiding all the foods that
you enjoy
in favor of foods that you kind of hate
obviously there are some things that
greg suggests that i don't necessarily
side with
and sometimes the things that he does
himself are different than
what he suggests others do but i do get
why that is since he himself says that
he's got very specific fitness goals
and he's a lot more disciplined and
motivated than he acknowledges
most people to be very true so of course
a big reminder that even when an
influencer knows what they're talking
about
greg or myself included what they do
themselves may not be beneficial to you
in your health journey so folks to sum
it up you are probably seeing some
general trends in the information that
i've chosen to highlight in this
super top level summary here so to recap
here are my thoughts it's my opinion
that you will not sustain any weight
loss diet
or lifestyle that encourages severe
physical restriction a feeling of
emotional
scarcity or deprivation demonizing foods
or food groups
or barriers for you to enjoy your damn
life sure you might lose some weight but
you will gain it
right back when you drop that
restrictive diet and start eating
normally again
and actually we know that this weight
cycling pattern
is arguably more dangerous from a
metabolic perspective
than just never losing the weight in the
first place
so in order to have a shot at changing
your behaviors and your eating patterns
in the long run with the potential
outcome of weight loss
we really need to bring it back to
basics
so that means number one adding more
fruits and veggies to your diet
fruits and veggies are rich in situating
fiber energizing carbs
and are naturally lower in calories this
does not however mean
subsisting off of fruit and veggies
alone to reach your weight loss goals
to the point where it's displacing other
healthy foods and that brings me to my
next point
number two eating adequate sources of
lean protein
and healthy fats both of which are
important for satiety
and overall nutrition and the former for
maintaining metabolically active muscle
mass
number three including movement in your
day that's enjoyable
and sustainable including some
resistance training
which will help to build muscle mass and
support your metabolism
it does not need to be an extreme gym
session to count but
try to be as active as you can without
encroaching on
other enjoyable parts of your life so
it's a general rule of thumb
anywhere between 30 to 60 minutes of
movement a day
doing something that makes you feel good
can have both physical
and mental benefits number four avoiding
extreme behaviors like completely
restricting foods or food groups that
you
love eating too little exercising too
much
skipping meals when you're hungry etc
remember that both
physical deprivation and emotional
scarcity
can both set you up for a binge number
five
think moderate deficit not denial
on a very primitive mathematical level
yes
losing weight requires that you burn
more calories than you consume
period is it that simple no not at all
because
there are a lot of compensatory
mechanisms at play that can make this
a minus b equation not always perfectly
equal
c however whether you choose to count
calories manage portion sizes
or aim to eat more lower calorie higher
fiber voluminous fruits and veggies to
kind of edge out some of those higher
calorie snacks
find a way to make small changes to your
overall intake
without triggering a sense of
deprivation
once we cross that line with extreme
cleanses or fast or cutting out whole
food groups that we love
the trust is broken and the diet
generally fails ultimately you want to
make the
diet fit the person not fit the person
to the diet
so be gentle with yourself honor your
needs
and make it work for you in a way that's
sustainable
and doesn't make you feel deprived and
finally
consider the holistic picture yes
nutrition is arguably the most important
piece in the weight loss puzzle
exercise being second but these things
do not happen
in a vacuum and when i worked clinically
we used to always say
that it is never just about the food
there are so many other external factors
that are at play
that can influence our ability to reach
our weight loss goals
whether that's genetics food security
income or physical environment stress
anxiety etc so focus
on the things that you can control with
the resources that you
do have and also make sure to take care
of the things that go beyond just
physical activity and nutrition so
things like
taking care of your emotional health
getting enough sleep
managing stress and addressing emotional
eating triggers
unfortunately there is nothing
sensationalized or sexy about this
this is all just basic nutrition 101
and it just takes a little education a
lot of practice
and your own innate intuition to truly
get it
so shout out to the weight loss creators
that i highlighted today for sifting
through some of the noise
a reminder that i may not agree with
everything and that means i still want
all of you to approach
each of these channels with a critical
lens
ultimately not every message is going to
be supportive to
every person and their relationship with
food and their body
but my goal here was to highlight
through other youtubers
what i perceive to be the most likely
information
to inspire long-term change so that is
all today thanks again to buildbar for
sponsoring this video
let me know in the comments if you liked
it and you want to see more videos like
this
if you did of course subscribe to the
channel give it the thumbs up
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you